of course it's nearly impossible to
graft performance into your application
after it's already been built but before
we get into good performance patterns
the first step to ensuring great
performance is being able to analyze
your performance I want to introduce you
to Colt McAnlis who you may remember
from his excellent html5 game
development course Colts going to show
you how to analyze your performance
using the chrome developer tools many
developers take way too long to start
addressing performance in their
applications you see they get under
timelines and schedules and they try to
get features checked in and all these
other things and way too late in the
game they actually realize that
performance is actually a huge issue but
you because you're watching this video
and we're having this little private
one-on-one talk are not going to fall
into that same pattern instead you're
going to do two things to stay out of it
now the first thing you're going to do
is you're actually going to follow the
perf matters hashtag on your favorite
social media network there's a lot of
smart people talking a lot about web
performance all over the net and
following this hashtag is going to get
you keyed in to the exact problems on
the net and how to fix them the second
thing you're going to do is you're
actually going to become an amazing
ninja at using chrome developer tools to
find your performance problems now we're
going to walk through some of the key
scenarios and some of the key tools that
you're going to use to address these
problems let's take a look